let's say we have two reservoirs
let's say
up here
i have my hot reservoir it's at t h for
hot
and i have my
engine it's going to be a carnot engine
because we'll learn that no no engine is
better at least from an efficiency point
of view we have to be careful when we
say better we have our carnot engine and
it takes it operates on heat
differentials so it takes some heat from
our hot heat source
it takes
some heat there let's call that q1
and it does some work
it does some work works a good thing so
i'll make that in green
it does some work
and then the the surplus energy
essentially goes to a cold
so the the surplus heat
q2 then goes to our cold reservoir
i'll do that right there
t
cold
now i made multiple insinuations in the
previous video that this is the most
efficient that this is the most
efficient engine that can be created
between two heat between two reservoirs
th and tc
now you come along and say no no no no
no i know of a friend he has invented of
a he's invented a new engine that is
more efficient than this engine between
these same two reservoirs and you go and
you you proceed to draw the same type of
diagram for your friend's engine
for your friend's engine you say look
let me make it clear this is the same
reservoir
right these same reservoirs we're
dealing with
i should probably draw this line all the
way because i'm going to do multiple
engines here
so the same reservoir we're dealing with
right this is all the hot reservoir th
th and this is all the cold reservoir i
need space for multiple engines that
we're going to deal with so your friend
has an engine
and we'll call it the super engine
super engine
and your friend's claim
and i
your friends claim and i'll show you why
your friend's claim cannot be true if
you believe the second law of
thermodynamics
so your friends claim
they have the super engine and they
claim that look i can actually take in
q1
i can take in that same heat
from this heat source up here but i can
produce more work than your engine i can
produce
than your carnot engine i could produce
one plus
x
i don't want to get too algebraic but
let's say
you produce w i produce w times one plus
x
of work
where x is a positive number so he's
saying look x is greater than zero
whatever that number he might feed you
is and then the rest of the energy
that's left over
the the rest of the energy that's left
over is what it's q1
minus this so it's q1
minus
w times one plus
x
and just to be clear q2 right here i
could rewrite that as q1 minus w
fair enough so you look at that you you
come to me with this and i say no no no
this this cannot be true because if this
were then we would solve literally all
of the world's energy problems and i'm
about to show you why we could solve all
of the world's energy problems and we
would have a perpetual motion machine
and and be able to defy all sorts of
things if we had this now i had this is
my carno engine but i could devise a
reverse carnot engine right let me make
a reverse carnot engine
so my reverse carnot engine
would look like this
carno reverse
and it's going to do the same thing but
in reverse so instead of taking instead
of producing q1 minus w here
instead of producing q1 minus w and
putting it into tc
it could take in
q1
i want to make sure i don't run out of
space it could take in
q1
minus
w from our cold source
so it could take that in or even better
let's scale it up a little bit let's
take let's say it takes in q1 minus w
times one plus x
so i've just made a slightly larger
reverse carnot engine now if i take in
that much
and then if i
in order to do this in reverse i'm going
to have to take in i'm going to have to
scale up this carnot engine and reverse
everything so instead of producing work
i'm not going to need work to go in the
other direction and i've scaled it up by
1 plus x so i'm going to need
1 plus i'm gonna need my the amount of
work
here times 1 plus x
times 1 plus x and then i'm going to
produce
i'm going to push
q1 but i've scaled it up i'm going to
push in q1 times 1 plus x into my hot
heat source and once again this isn't
defined the laws of thermodynamics i'm
taking up some work i need there's work
that needs to be done in order to do
this
but all of a sudden you you you come to
me and say look we this is this is an
awesome deal you have this nice engine
that works this way my friend has the
super engine let's just couple them
together let's take the work that he
produces
right here
he produces w times one plus x and that
just happens to be the amount of work
that you need to operate your engine so
you just feed that into there so what's
the net effect of these two engines
what's the net effect of these two
engines
so if i were to do let me do another
let me
scroll a little bit more actually that
might be the best way to do it
so let me
make sure that we understand that these
are the same
heat sinks or heat sources that we're
using the whole time so that's my hot
source
my cold source is down here
so if i add our two engines together so
if i have a
you know let me call it a
let me pick a new color these colors are
getting monotonous
nope i wanted to do the
rectangle tool there you go
all right so i combined these two
engines together essentially i just put
a big box around them they're both
operating between these two heat sources
these two reservoirs so i call this the
you know your super engine plus my
reverse carno engine
so what's happening now
what's the net what's the net
heat that's being that's being taken in
or put out of here so we have we have q1
so in this direction we have let me say
we have q1
minus w 1 plus x but in this direction
so this is in this direction we could
rewrite this i want to make sure you're
clear on the algebra this could be
rewritten as what is q1 times 1 plus x
times
or minus w times 1 plus x
right now and these and if you compare
these terms
this is the same as this term
this term is bigger than this term right
this term is clearly bigger because
we're multiplying it by something larger
than one it's bigger than this term so
this upward if we combine these two the
upward movement
from my reverse or the amount of heat
i'm taking up from my reverse carnot is
going to be greater than the amount of
heat being put in by your friend's super
engine and we can actually calculate the
amount we can just take this amount
minus that amount and that's the net
upward movement
so the net upward movement from our cold
reservoir is what
it's this value minus this value so
minus
q1 minus w1 plus x
if we take a minus we're going to
subtract it so it's minus and a plus
these cancel out
this minus cancels out with so this
first term could be rewritten as
q1 plus q1x
right we could rewrite it that way so
this cancels out with that and so the
net upward movement when we combine the
two engines is q
one
times x
fair enough now what about the work
transfer well whatever work this guy
produces is exactly the amount of work
that i need so there is no net no
outside work has to be done on the
system it just works this guy produces
work this guy uses the work now what's
the net heat transferred up to our hot
reservoir
to our hot reservoir what's the amount
of heat
what's the difference between these two
and this is clearly a larger number than
this one so we have the upward movement
dominates so what's this minus that so
this can be rewritten as q1 plus
q1x
right i just distributed the q1 we're
going to subtract that out minus q1 left
with q1x so the net movement when we
combine the two engines is q1
x
so what's happening here
i have no external energy or work has to
be expanded into this system
and it's just it's just taking heat from
a cold body and it's moving it to a warm
body and it does this indefinitely it'll
do this as much as i want to i can just
build a bigger one it'll do it on even a
larger and larger scale so if you think
about it i mean i could i could i could
i could heat my house with ice by just
making the ice colder i could i could
you know i could create steam from from
things that are arbitrarily cold
this this is just this goes against the
second law of thermodynamics this is you
know the the net entropy in this world
is going down because
what's happening here this is just a
straight up transfer of q1x from a cold
body to a hot body so what's the net
change in entropy here
the change in entropy of the universe
well the hot body
the hot body is gaining some heat so
it's q1
x
over
over the temperature of the hot body and
then the cold body is losing the same
amount so it's minus q1 x
over the cold body
now this is a bigger number this is a
bigger number than this is right because
this is us the denominator is smaller
this is a cold body its temperature and
kelvin will be a smaller number so this
is going to be less than
zero which the second law of
thermodynamics tells us cannot be the
entropy cannot shrink in the universe
this whole thing is just a it's an
independent system and the entropy is
shrinking and we can make the entropy
shrink arbitrarily if we just scale up
our x's enough so this is why the carnot
engine is the most efficient engine
possible because if anyone claimed to
have a more efficient engine you could
couple it with a reverse carno engine
and then create this perpetual reverse i
guess you could call it a perpetual
refrigeration machine that just out of
out of the blue creates
anti-entropy from anywhere and it would
be this perpetual energy source that
creates energy out of nothing and so
this is just something that cannot be
done in our world especially if you
believe the second law of thermodynamics
so the most efficient engine is the
carnot engine where its efficiency is
described as one minus the temperature
of the cold body divided by the hot body
so if i have two temperature reservoirs
let's say that my hot one is at
500 kelvin
and my cold one is at
300 kelvin
and i have some engine that that takes
heat from there and transfers there and
does some work the most efficient engine
if i were to remove all the friction in
the engine the most efficient the
highest efficiency i could get would be
one minus
300 kelvin over 500 kelvin which is one
minus three fifths
which is two-fifths
two-fifths which is equal to point four
which is equal to
forty percent
so if someone tells you that they made
an engine that takes that that operates
between a
a a reservoir that's 500 kelvin and 300
kelvin and they say oh i i've achieved
41 efficiency i've really polished the
thing well you know that they are lying
so anyway hopefully you found that
reasonably interesting and and i'll see
in the next video